I'm telling you I saw that cat do stuff
for soldiers kids who'd been abused
Haitians after storms yeah sometimes the
the in the matter the way that doesn't
matter the topical stuff I sometimes
find him equally ill at ease as I am
yeah
but walking the walk and that cat gave a
lot of money to a lot of people I don't
want to do the greatest hits with you
because I want to I want to do sort of
where you're at now but so when you then
start doing O'Reilly and then suddenly
people are going wait a minute this is
SNL Weekend Update guys like this sort
of like hip cool live kind of suddenly
around or super cool or is not hip and
cool I was the same but but the optics
of it now suddenly wait and this doesn't
make sense he was on SNL and now he's on
evil Fox News I'm just saying you know
there's not my opinion this is just
little people yeah yeah
what did you fear that at all or even
none of it interesting listen I was on
the number one rated show on cable I
think bill for twenty years I was doing
six minutes a week it was a beautiful
gig we've got on the road once a week
whatever once a month
we'd sell 1000 crazy could you believe
that could he believe it we definitely
were one plus one equals three thing
mm-hmm cuz on my own I'd probably at
that point dropped to I don't know what
Billy was John but probably to yeah well
you put us together in the mutton Jeff
of it it always reminded me that scene
in the Chaplin movie not saying we're
Chaplin high score Charlie puts his foot
behind his leg and kicks the guy who's
working the border guard or the guy at
LSI kicks him in the butt I was doing
that to around yeah and the key moment
in that relationship was when I told
Billy you're like a big Mick beat cop
Irish meat beat cop where you're
spinning that stick everybody's scared
shitless see you and I'm gonna call you
Billy I got a bill that why was a great
move because all of a sudden the the
power the the monolith
as being poked fun at by this the mutton
Jeff guy and it was it was cool that's
why it works again there is because I
could make him laugh not an unguarded
laugh periodically mm-hmm and I could
poke fun at him I could call him Billy
I could wear shorts on his show which
you know I put my leg up do you not at
all that worked you know those are you
doing a lot of those hits from home did
you have a home situation and were you
going into Fox millions of them I went
over this place called the Reuben
studios no I I think we did it up at
Santa Barbara in another studio we're
always on split screen it was so funny
until we started going on the road
people would say you'll bill it like
we're hoping to Crosby is I you know
I've met her place we're always on a
split screen but over the years I'll
tell you what I'm relatively ill ities
socially I don't know what that is I
don't wanna make it precious bill I
think if you can watch over the years
are you look as I don't cuz off camera
you seem exactly the same to me we're
know but there's plenty of comics I know
exactly what you're talking about it's a
lot of comics that are weird have eye
contact stuff don't want to touch
anybody and then the second you know the
camera goes on and bam they're they're
there but I don't from the little bit we
just did our thing I didn't catch that
well I I do know that I don't go to a
lot of social events and stuff like that
when I'm working I mean a hail fellow
well met I like to say I'd be normal I'm
in a cat's place and but I'm not a real
social guy and he isn't either so when
you put the two of us together I was
enamored of that part over a rally and I
sometimes didn't understand his brusque
manner and I sometimes thought why is he
beating his drum to that degree when I'd
watch him on a show and bill if you're
seeing this I you know I'm not you know
I I'm telling I saw that cat do stuff
for soldiers kids who'd been abused
Haitians after storms yeah
sometimes the the in the matter the way
that doesn't matter the topical stuff I
sometimes find him equally ill at ease
as I am yeah but walking the walk and
that cat gave a lot of money to a lot of
people and I don't know his personal
life you know people say what about I go
do you really think oh okay so that's
that's my relationship with our ally
I'm gonna call him talking about dating
or whatever the hell is going on right
it's not my life with him
we went out on the road and I saw him do
a lot of good things for a lot of people
and guess what I felt no need to know to
probe the underbelly of Bill O'Reilly or
find out what really makes him tick and
he felt no need to find out that being
said I I did seem do enough things over
the years that I find him an honorable
man yeah what do you think about the way
that we take out people these days you
have to make it about him specifically
but just generally you know now Chris
Matthews went out it's just like this
endless cascade of we're just gonna
build people up and crush them gets
worse
you know imagine like Twitter during
Dickensian England
I mean it's not worse than it's ever
been that's what everyone says every day
it's worse than it's ever been
I think the way that'll turn this yeah
it might be but I think the way the
little turn is is everybody who's in the
public eye should get up to a joke a
witticism a pithy revelation and stop it
down themselves and look at the camera
and say I have something here but I'm
going to stay out because I understand
the new rules and have that happen at
nauseam for a few years and I relate to
people how crazy and our post or welling
and it's gotten as far as jokes dialogue
throwaways cruelty indeed humans are
cruel once in a while you know the fact
that that's all neutered on now I think
that people should be reminded that
we're missing some of the texture of
life walking around like we're in
Logan's Run or something you know it's a
I I don't think it will change for a
while because to me it's the Lord of the
Flies and right now the uptight people
have the conch and they're the ones that
are gonna speak and therefore if I'm
sitting there and I get to a point in a
joke where I go this this puts me where
I have to talk to people who I disagree
with about how bad I am I just I stopped
off it and yeah yeah I'm not gonna say
it yeah I've tackled myself here and if
enough of that happens people are gonna
start saying hey I'm sick of this yeah
do you have a bunch that you just
wouldn't tell anymore like it's like an
old favorite that you're just like yeah
that's it's easy listen one I used to be
on network television they told you not
to swear I find that easy not to swear
when I'm in Vegas
find that easy to say fun when I'm here
I don't know what the rules are here
you'll bleep oh no we don't believe it
yeah that's a canceled right now I mean
I don't think about it but I am saying
that yes and not so much this point at
all my career we tell you I don't care
about that I care about having to spend
time reacting to Nimrods who quite
frankly think second-guessing is
creativity it isn't I like being with
creative people I like being with people
who say things occasional I can't
believe you said that and I don't think
it's over then and I listen the human
the you would Frey is cacophonous it's
like that where was it written that
you're never going to hear anything that
falls on your you know philia in your
ear and you disagree with it I wouldn't
want I don't want to lead that life so
well therefore I'll stop myself just
because I think Christ who needs to
bring down a some white kid telling me
how I've ruined his day yeah you know I
used to do if there's some my old
stand-up tapes are right there and I
used to do a joke way back when that I
used to say the n-word and it was not to
be racist in any way it was actually a
stupid silly transformers reference that
I was imitating a transformer and I
would say it would always get a huge
laugh huge laugh I would close with it
sometimes and then one night I was on
stage at Gotham comedy club on 24th and
the audience kind of turned on me this
is like maybe 2004 something like that
and I remember thinking I'm putting that
one away and I never did it again and
ever I never liked that feeling but I
was just like yeah this is where you
want to do a Nantucket sleigh ride with
a bit where they ride it to the bottom
yeah doesn't interest me yeah come out
there to please people I like to get
laughs and at some point if I have an
opinion and I feel it's worth it
I'll push it in even if it draws ire but
there are other times I think this isn't
good enough to let this all this agita
into my life the sermon dranks tiresome
yeah you know it's so precious to me
that we sit down every day and ten times
a day somebody has to get themselves
back and spine and I remember when years
ago there was a cat who is the general
manager for the Los Angeles
al campanis do you remember him yeah
yeah this head before I was here bare he
goes on Ted Koppel one night and he says
something that's like from another
generation racially and he's dead you
know he's he's got to go supplicate for
sharped and you know all that silly game
and because her Sharpton so righteous
yeah and I remember thinking you know
when Jackie Robinson first came up and
he goes to Montreal and the Dodgers he's
playing minor league baseball and they
got to assign somebody to go out with a
cat and write you know right wing man I
think Kemp anis is right there I mean
when it came to real life yeah there
yeah and then later he says something
brutish from a dead day gone by and he's
over and I remember thinking oh this is
so tedious you know that's the smartest
thing Eric Holder ever said although I
think he backed back-ended into I don't
even think he meant it the way I took it
when he said we're cowards we don't even
have chats about things anymore
racial relations indeed we don't and
guess what you want to be the first guy
in really you want to be over this
afternoon trying to make some sort of
lucid nuanced comment about interactions
between human beings of different colors
and you're done if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about comedy instead of the nonstop
yelling you get everywhere else check
out our comedy playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and you get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell